At UCLA in 1969, the very first Internet message was sent.
Kleinrock's team of computer scientists sent it to another team of computer wizards...
...at the Stanford Research Institute.
That first message was supposed to be the word "log" as in "log in".
Charlie typed the "L". He said, "Did you get the L?"
"Yup! I got the L."
"Type the O. Got the O?"
"I got the O."
"Type the G. Did you get the G?"
Crash!
The SRI computer crashed.
So the first message ever on the Internet was "lo"!...
...as in "lo and behold."
Just a few years later, the very first e-mail was sent on this ARPANET system.
Ray Tomlinson wrote the code that allowed text messages to be sent to users on different computers...
...rather than to one shared computer.
Scientists began to share personal messages with each other.
"How are the wife and kids?"
You know, "How are you doing? When are you gonna go to this conference?"
Or "What are you gonna do on your summer vacation?"
At this point in the 1970s, the spread of the Internet was still an apparatus...
...used by a select elite few, mostly from the world of academia.
It was the introduction of the personal computer in 1981...
...that started the massive migration of humanity to the Internet.
When IBM came out with the PC and Microsoft came up with DOS,...
...that's what put it into the hands of normal people.